this Moss is brilliant for soaking up  the water so who thinks is the snake we  like microwaves yeah so I'm gonna find  you some special mud and it's up where  we've just been no button talkin so it's  really dry that's because it's all on  sand and gravel in that so it's very  well trained back down here again very  very wet and this special mud is what  it's all about an old adage you  understand on the bridge there I'll go  get something I'm just gonna go down  here and round and I'll see you back go  free under the bridge in a minute the  helpers very heavy  this is quite a lot of iron so that and  then so it's oxidizing there so it's not  white top quality and then some of it is  Brittany and others really quite done  right and that just me  but it will dry again in a crumble on  Lobos home you get back to the car that  will be dry